the Joe Rogan experience the Weger
situation is shockingly under-covered oh
my god well it demonstrates them when
people said never again they were full
grab they're just full of crap I mean
it's not true in the this is one area
where the United States should
absolutely be taking a leading role it
is obvious that China is a nefarious
actor China's been stealing our
technology
China is attacked the Chinese government
is attempting to extend its rule of
tyranny over Hong Kong they just
objected 7.5 million people to their
direct guarantee and violation of
trading and the response has basically
been muted from the Western world and
did you see that did you see that video
of the the Chinese ambassador in Britain
being asked on the BBC about that tape
no I didn't mean it's fantastic so the
BBC interview or shows him the tape of
the people being pushed onto trains
right and he says what is this and the
Chinese ambassador says I can't see it
I'm not sure what you're talking about
he's literally saying that the screen is
huge - right behind him like he's
looking right at it
any access that we can't see it and then
he starts talking about the natural
beauty of the region right here he won't
he won't deal with it he won't you won't
explain what it is and the rest of the
world is just like well you know what
this is where you know in the sporting
world the whole the the story that's
under covered in the sporting world is
the is the blowback on that the NBA gave
to general Maury the the Houston Rockets
GM for saying free Hong Kong right you
can't even get anyone in the NBA to
condemn China while China's subjecting a
million we Gers to abject slavery
Mark Cuban just had an exchange with Ted
Cruz the other day where where he was
going after Cruz for something and Cruz
said we'll just you know he questioned
Cruz Cruz balls or something and Cruz
came back and said well do you have the
balls to condemn China and Cuban said
something like well you know I don't
want to I don't want to get involved in
the internal affairs of another country
I thought well that's dad is not an
internal affairs question it's one thing
to say I don't want to get involved in
the tax rates of other countries another
thing to say
shaving people's heads shipping them on
trains to concentration camps where you
force them into labor and or sterilize
them that seems like not an internal
issue that you're not allowed to
criticize really yeah that's a big one
but the the China thing is so crazy
because so many so many business
interests have this connection with them
and so much of the money that they
generate is because of China I mean the
NBA films there's also there's so much
so much of our culture the
cows to China we're so connected to them
that's one of the things that we really
found out from this pandemic is how many
things are built there how much of our
medicine how much we rely on China it
also demonstrates the lie of the idea
that if you trade with somebody then
they're going to liberalize yeah that
was no something that was pushed over
the last 3040 years real hard which is
we'll help them out economically we'll
have mutual trade it'll be good for both
of us and they'll liberalize because
once they realize it's good to be part
of the world economy then they won't be
tyrunt's anymore and instead they just
took all the chips off the table and
said no actually I'm gonna double down
on this and we're gonna get more
tyrannical not less I mean she is the
most powerful Chinese leader since male
it's incredible
[Applause]